how's recall going i saw uh
uh what's his name meet kevin wasn't
stephen colbert talked about him
yesterday he's catching a moment i'll
tell you what you know the mainstream
media doesn't give anybody any any love
whatsoever you would think larry elder
you know what a great story if you think
about him born and raised in compton a
self-made man african-american
millionaire
just smart achieved so much in his life
built a business uh he gets nothing so
you're going to have to do it all on
your own but i just think i think he's
going to get recalled i i'm i'm going
about 52 to 48 right now that it's going
to happen i just have the balance yeah i
brought it with me here's the sample
ballot right here me kevin is on here
kevin you know he's really you know
picking up some momentum cnnbc did a big
story on him over the weekend i saw that
yeah great story i sent it to him it's a
great story yeah um let me see so where
do i go for the battle it's just like
right right when you get in there oh
really it's two options yes or no so
listen i'm mainly looking for the zen or
last name is what i'm uh
that's the write-in box i know shonda
yeah that's what i'm looking for well
she's satisfied being dictator of my
house
i like that okay so what do i look at
here it's so so they have made this more
complicated so which of the candidates
would go okay right here yeah so yes or
no and then it's all the candidates so
what you're looking at is the main names
are at the top right so candidates to
succeed governor newsom uh as governor
if he is recalled vote for one michael
loebs
party reference none universally
lecturer is who he is
dennis denise lucy teacher
diego martinez then he got a bunch of
different names well he's not on that
list right what's this list that's it's
continued it's that's everybody people
you can you go to second page so larry
elder then it's meet kevin
uh and then john cox is below elder
because most of a person's not going to
go
so how do they do it when it just shows
democrat or republican because that's
how a lot of people would vote i think
so too most of them are republican
there's only a few democrats meet kevin
is maybe one of two democrats harley's
one of them who's running as a democrat
jack clean mcgowan
is running as a democrat
john drake jeff hewitt running as a
libertarian riverside county supervisor
by the way i interviewed yesterday uh uh
a doctor what's his last name kai dr
bear is it bear
assatar bear who's a full-blown
communist professor at
riverside community college so weird
who's professor to be a communist you
never see that i asked by the way david
did we get longer did we get along great
you guys got along what was the
connection like
long time friend
at the end he says look i want to take
you out to dinner and when we go out to
dinner i want to pay for it i'm like you
don't want to pay for it
but i asked him a question it was a very
interesting question you'd be blown away
by his answer he thinks
mao
and he thinks stalin are two of the
greatest leaders of all time okay so i
asked him a question i said let me ask
you this i said say a 22 year old kid is
watching this interview and me and you
are talking i'm a capitalist you're a
communist he says yes i said this 22
year old kid has to choose he's very
ambitious very driven extremely
motivated he has a choice what's better
to society in the world he chooses to be
the next jeff bezos where the next 20
years he creates 1.3 million jobs for
america or he chooses to be a
revolutionary leader like stalin who's
better for society he said it's not even
close it's stalin oh my god what what 50
million people dead i mean that's
collateral damage i guess what did he
say when i said that he says but that's
part of the sacrifice
that's part of it that's why that's part
of the sacrifice yeah
50 million did make that choice i'm
telling you this was one of the most
interesting energies i can't wait for
this thing to come audience has to see
it it was
but the part that you respect about it
was purely shameless like he wasn't a
commie that's like but no it's noble and
this is so funny i i could see the two
of you guys going out to dinner he's
like no no pat i've got this i've got
this and then going table to table going
like i need ten dollars from you i need
ten dollars the sad thing is though you
can you can realize what it is it's
folly the guy's crazy but think about
the influence he has on 30 people a day
when he's throwing that message out
there to his students it's unbelievable
vulnerable kids at the age of eighteen
nineteen point an eighteen-year-old with
four four yeah
eighteen-year-old would fall for it
everybody's economy until they start
paying taxes yeah
that's right and anyways it was very
interesting by the way caitlyn jenner is
also on the list but they have her all
they have them all the way at the bottom
right all the way at the bottom so what
do you think is going to end up
happening here by the way you kind of
have an idea you kind of because it's
probably on the news every day in
california yes and no um it's such
propaganda i mean the la times is fully
behind gavin newsom they're making you
feel like you're stupid if you even
think anything else all you know so reid
hastings kicked in three million dollars
right to him but that was like three
months yeah but right now you're seeing
that money in action because it's all
used on radio ads radio and television
interesting yeah so every at the tag of
every these every one of these
commercials paid for by reed hastings by
his donation so it's a constant i mean
you listen to the dodgers game you
listen to anything pop radio boom you're
getting those commercials all the time
and it's basically shaming you into even
think that you would vote yes on the
recall it's saying it's all driven by
right wing nut jobs and which is not by
the way it's not at all anti-vaxxers
things like that they're throwing the
mask mandate into it at all into as well
but there is no question newsome's
nervous none at all he's he's he's
snapping at press conferences
yes he's snapping about all this i'm
like whoa and that's what happens when
you have a media that just throws you
softballs every single day when they
actually challenge you able to put that
video up kai or no where he's saying
uh uh stop bitching about people are
bitching about what's going on in
california you know he's got that one
voice just let me be corrupt oh my god
how hard is this how much money am i
giving you just let me be correct more
handouts you know if the thing that
makes me a little bit nervous is the
mail in ballots you know how those are
going to be counted hopefully
effectively
are you suggesting i'm not suggesting
anything i'm just saying when you mail
that much stuff you're relying on the
u.s postal service and then it's a
minimum wage account did you leave a
video that's going viral right now where
people are going around pulling the
recall ballots out did you see that yeah
out of mailboxes right pretty crazy i
want to send it to you here an airdrop
tell me which one to send it to i i
tried explaining this a couple podcasts
ago like uh to adam exactly like how
ballot harvesting works in big cities
and what they do like literally you put
the the ballot boxes in these giant
section eight you know eight-story
ten-story uh developments and you go
door-to-door and you say hey look sign
this sign this sign to sign this maybe
you give them a small incentive five
dollars whatever or you you look at who
they voted for and you're like i'll take
it it's older people they're like i'll
take it for you no problem you clip it
open and you're like oop that guy goes
no absolutely not dump this so they they
ballot harvest it would take a team of
two people all right remember we talked
about there's two there's two different
moving factors in politics you have the
greedy and you have the crazy the crazy
not the greedy are the ones on the
ground donating their time spending all
day going door to door so those people
aren't playing it straight those people
aren't aren't here to be civil servants
for you they're here to make sure their
side wins so they're taking these
ballots they're looking at which ballots
benefit them and they're ditching the
other ones man you know the crazy thing
is every name on this ballot you ask
them a year ago this wasn't on their
radar screen the last thing they
probably thought they'd be doing is
being the governor of the fifth biggest
economy in the world i mean if we vote
no or yes on on removing him someone on
this list is going to be the governor
and you wonder how prepared they are how
they can handle that super majority in
california the democrats still have
control of power you know so it's going
to be a tough job whoever gets it but
anything would be better than what we
have how is it not on our phones we can
verify literally everything how is it
not
how is what not on our phone voting oh
how is voting not only how is it not
digitized how is it not you you take
like you literally can just facetime in
you see that it's me and i say i just
verbally say who it is but that's
offensive though how dare you how how
dare you assume people have bothered
cell phones if you're watching this just
out of curiosity if you're watching this
thumbs up you want to see this guy be
recalled governor newsome thumbs down
just smash it right there when you see
it on your phone it's not hard you don't
need to type it just press thumbs up i
want to see newsome be recalled thumbs
down no i kind of want to
see in there because i don't think
anybody can do a better job than i'm
curious kai can you play that video i
just want to show the first 10 seconds
watch this
what the hell
he is going crazy he's sideways wait
wait wait go back go back you missed it
go back go back a little bit okay go
ahead
nice
if our homegrown team start focusing on
what's right
everybody outside this state
is bitching about this state
you should see what he continues saying
by the way
he really loses in this one press
conference by the way it's not it's not
a pretty sight for him so if you enjoyed
this little short segment from the
podcast that we did here's another short
segment to watch or if you want to see
the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody bye
[Music]